[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici lé titre les retombées pour
l'emploi et l'économie seront
probablement importante est maximale
pour tirer un profit de l'organisation
des jeux olympiques dans six ans à paris
le medef lance une plateforme
entreprises 2024 une réunion
d'information était organisée jeudi au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines il est
candidat à la présidence de la
fédération locale des républicains face
à pierre bédier alexandra dublanche jean
philippe girod veut porter la voix des
militants cet adhérent et directeur du
développement international d'une pme
sera l'invité de l'émission
dans le reste de l'actualité la
concertation publique lancée pour la
rénovation du quatrième du quartier des
quatre arbres à elancourt ou encore le
premier forum parentalité organisé à la
verrière mercredi de la patience pour ce
week-end de pentecôte vous en aurez
besoin si vous avez la chance de partir
bison futé prévoit de nombreux
ralentissements sur les routes
franciliennes jusqu'à lundi et notamment
dans le sens des départs la journée est
classée rouge ce vendredi orange samedi
les conseillé d'emprunter les grands
axes avant 8 heures ou après 21 heures
dans le sens des retours la journée de
lundi est orange aussi la circulation
sera saturé au niveau du péage de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines après 15h
selon bison futé
prenez vos précautions les
ralentissements sur la route et dans les
transports en commun aussi nouvelle
journée de grève des cheminots jusqu'à
dimanche matin les lignes n ai eu du
transilien et le est reversée pour vous
rendre ou partir de saint quentin en
yvelines seront impactés l état du
trafic et les horaires de vos trains
sont disponibles sur transilien.com le
medef a présenté jeudi soir au vélodrome
nationale la plateforme entreprises 2024
opérationnel dès le 1er octobre prochain
elle permettra aux entrepreneurs d'avoir
un accès privilégié aux appels d'offres
liés aux jo-2000 24 l'organisation
patronale organisée une
d'information pour les entrepreneurs sur
le sujet au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines un reportage
d'aurélie rose informations sur les jeux
olympiques de 2024 appel à projets appel
d'offres ou encore emploi en lançant la
plateforme entreprises 2024 le medef
souhaite faire profiter les entreprises
de cette opportunité économique le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
sera particulièrement concernée puisque
quatre sites accueilleront des épreuves
le rendez-vous est dans six ans et
pourtant c'est maintenant qu'il faut
anticiper on n'a pas du tout le droit à
l'erreur c'est la planète qui nous
regardent et c'est un vrai facteur de
rayonnement pour la france que d'avoir
l'accueil de ces jeux olympiques
donc on ne peut pas se louper et donc
c'est de la préparation et la
planification la plateforme entreprises
2024 également dédié aux associations
sera mise en route dès le 1er octobre
2018 pour l'instant aucun chiffre précis
sur les retombées économiques
les jeux olympiques devrait néanmoins
créé 250 mille emplois pour 50 ans avec
les sites qui existent déjà il ya une
part hôtelière il part dans le bâtiment
c'est une vraie opportunité s'il ya un
manque de main d'oeuvre dans certains
secteurs et en mettre en place des
formations en adéquation avec la demande
lors de cette présentation de sportif
françois pervis et quentin lafargue ont
partagé avec les entrepreneurs leur
parcours et leur motivation pour
atteindre le plus haut niveau
quand on est
patron d'une entreprise ou salarié ou
collaborateurs on a des objectifs de
réussite
et forcément quand on est sportif de
haut niveau c'est la même chose tout
comme les sportifs les entrepreneurs
yvelinois pourront mettre toutes leurs
chances de leur côté grâce à cette
plateforme pour profiter au mieux de
l'événement suite et fin de notre
escapade au festival de cannes toute la
semaine la rédaction de tv 60,18 vous a
fait vivre l'évènement à travers les
yvelinois sur place pour ce dernier
numéro de cannes 78 plata place à la
musique et au groupe macadam crocodile
un reportage de grégory canale et alexis
garneau
villa schweppes plage du majestic ou
encore baoli la nuit cannoise bat son
plein pendant le festival 2 yvelinois
gavi polycarpe et vincent brunet ont
animé l'une de ses soirées à l'atelier
des merveilles éphémère le chanteur m
s'est également joint à la partie jeunes
et xavier et vincent ont fréquenté le
même lycée à la celle saint cloud après
leur carrière respective ils se sont
retrouvés et ont créé macadam crocodiles
[Musique]
xavier et vincent vous représentez donc
le groupe macadam crocodile vous
produisez ce samedi 12 mai sur la
terrasse du fei six hôtels dans le cadre
de la soirée des ateliers des merveilles
est éphémère parlez-nous déjà de
l'univers de macadam crocodile qui a dit
il cet univers c'est un univers qui est
retranscrit par nos deux faciès déjà est
annoncé tout part d'un d'une une sorte
de revenir 2
deux collectifs qu'on a depuis longtemps
on a beaucoup de jamais ensemble depuis
des années et des années et des années a
eu plein de projets ensemble on vient là
on a fait le même lycée etc
et voilà et l'univers c'était c'est
avant tout le vin le plaisir le plaisir
de joie et de se regarder dans les yeux
dessus un peu ça donne quoi musicalement
musicalement puisqu'elle mans c1
oui sa part donc d'une envie de jouer en
boucle de d'essayer de faire monter ce
qu'on peut dire une certaine trans dans
la musique apporter une certaine transe
avec la répétition mais on va dire que
lyon puisse nono faire nos influences
il ya de la fun de l'afro funk et
mélangé avec du disco du new disco
voilà il le truc plus moderne voilà un
peu trippant quand on peut dire aussi
qu'ils permettent de voilà deux des
longues montées des longues envolées et
c'est uniquement aussi les des
performances en live c'est ça jusqu
alors c'est qu'on a fait ou n'a rien
enregistré en fait on n'a rien
enregistré c'est que du live et on voit
là on a fait beaucoup de concerts donc
on se demande peut-être si on n'a pas
enregistré et le fait d'être présent ici
à cannes pendant le festival est ce que
c'est un choix de votre part peut-être
êtes-vous passionné de cinéma où ça
s'est fait tout à fait par hasard
cette programmation est faite de joie
ici ce soir c'est une très grosse
opportunité c'est une très grosse
opportunité pour pour cannes de nous
avoir en ce samedi 12 mais c'est vrai
enfin en fait le festival s'est
construit autour de nous ça veut dire
que cette année on voulait faire du
macadam crocodile avant tout on s'est
dit qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
peut-être qu'on peut faire un festival
de cinéma et si effectivement on aime
bien le cinéma et des films commencent
et c'est là c'est loïc a donc qui
s'occupe de l'âme c'est qu'il est à dire
que c'est dans un endroit où je joue ce
soir qui nous a contactés il ya des amis
ont ils nous ont proposé de venir au
festival depuis en aiguille avec toute
une bande de musiciens conques avec qui
on est amis on habite de jouer un peu
ensemble et il ya mathieu chedid qui
étaient là aussi donc c'est super on a
fait 1
une super jamie hier de deux heures et
qu'est-ce que vous avez concocté à ce
soir pour personnes qui vont assister à
cette performance de la sphère et
j'espère de l' envie de danser parce que
notre but c'est que les gens dansent et
faire plaisir et faire plaisir vous
faire danser les gens ont vraiment dans
ce truc là de faire partie de la de
faire partie de la fête quoi puisque
avec un show à proprement parler merci
vincent xhavit merci à toi que le
gorille
[Musique]
et puis dernier focus de la semaine sur
un film financé par la région
ile-de-france mari mange revient avec
joueurs premier long métrage de la
réalisatrice sélectionnés au sein de la
quinzaine des réalisateurs festival
parallèle à cannes joueurs se déroule
dans les milieux du jeu parisien est là
une jeune femme normale rencontre abel
un flambeur qui l'entraînent dans sa
passion et son addiction
50 50
on va manger un bout
[Musique]
l'écran
voilà c'est sur ces images que se
referme le rideau de cannes 78 merci de
nous avoir suivi toute cette semaine
khan 60 18,7 à revoir sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
un seul mandat d'élu local au début des
années 2000 il est pour l'instant
l'invité presque inconnu de la course à
la présidence de la fédération
yvelinoise des républicains jean
philippe girod militants et l'air dans
la 9e circonscription des yvelines
souhait de se mesurer à pierre bédier
président du département et alexandra
dublanche vice présidente de la région
ile de france tout comme eux il est
candidat pour devenir le patron de la
droite locale et il est aussi notre
invité pour cette émission jean philippe
girod bonsoir bonsoir nicolas je disais
méconnu pour un grand nombre d'yveline
wa ce n'est pas ce n'est pas une attaque
contre vous hormis peut-être pour ceux
de la 9e circonscription des yvelines
pourquoi vous avez décidé de vous lancer
dans cette dans cette campagne avec deux
poids lourds que sont pierre bédier
alexandra du blanche est passé justement
parce qu'il ya deux poids lourds qui
vont s'opposer pour la présidence de la
fédération des yvelines et à droite
on a beaucoup souffert de ces guerre des
chefs et en fait je leur envoie un
message je les ai rencontrés les uns et
les autres pour leur dire que je serai
le caillou dans leurs chaussures pour
essayer de trouver une voie qui mettrait
tous les militants autour d'un seul
projet est en fait on l'a vu lors des
élections sénatoriales c'est possible il
ya une voie de la raison entre pierre
bédier qui a été président et qui a une
très longue carrière politique et
alexandra du blanche qui représente la
nouvelle génération
il ya certainement une voix au milieu
sophie primas pourrait être cette
personne là à ce qui veut dire que vous
ne portez pas forcément vous une
ambition personnelle vous êtes là
surtout pour votre famille politique
alors je porte un projet j'incarne un
projet qui est de faire entendre la voix
des militants
je précise tout de suite je roule pour
personne d'accord pas parce que vous
parlez de riz sophie primas j'avais
monté sur site rima qui vous envoie un
peu en mission absolument pas et ça a
été très clair je m'en suis entretenu
avec elle les choses sont très claires
je fais campagne pour faire entendre la
voix des militants
sophie primas et
vice présidente de la commission des
affaires économiques au sénat la
sénatrice des yvelines
tout comme pierre bédier tout comme
alexandra dublanche à la forte affaire
elle a un emploi du temps très chargé
j'aimais pour autant une activité
professionnelle mais je n'ai pas de
mandat est donc en fait j'essaye de
d'appeler à la raison les poids lourds
des yvelines de ma famille politique
pour une solution qui convienne à tous
et qui convienne surtout aux militants
oui pour apprendre à mieux vous
connaître vous étiez élu je crois entre
2001 et 2008 dans un petit village des
yvelines en lui précisément pour aussi
apprendre à mieux vous connaître
est ce que vous pourriez définir votre
votre votre point de vue politique est
plutôt votre parcours idéologique
vous avez intégré le mp si je dis pas de
bêtises en soutenant à l'époque nicolas
dupont aignan qui était encore membre de
l'ump
est ce que ça veut dire que vous êtes un
souverainiste qui est un qui est
favorable au protectionnisme alors
effectivement je suis venu à la
politique est devenu adhérent à l'époque
de l'ump suite au mandat que j'ai
effectué j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer différents élus et j'ai senti
la force politique que représentait un
mandat nicolas dupont aignan
à l'époque quand son parti était associé
à l'ump présenté des idées qui était
pour moi plutôt gaulliste il va échapper
à personne qu'il s'en est fortement
éloignées et c'est pour cette raison
quand il a quitté l'ump que je ne l'est
pas suivi aujourd'hui
j'ai participé très activement à la
halle à droite forte avec geoffroy
didier et guillaume pelletier qui
incarnait une nouvelle génération
mais là encore je reste de la rue jaurès
fidèle à mes idées quand ils se sont
rapprochés fortement et sans informer
personne de sens commun on vous sait
géré en délégation de les suivre et du
coup aujourd'hui vous appartenait au
mouvement libre créé par valérie
pécresse il ya quelques mois et une
question du coût alexandra du blanche
avec le ticket qu'elle forme avec othman
nas ou très proche de valérie pécresse
pourquoi vous ne soutenez pas plus
qu'elle même et semble être la candidate
choisie par valérie pécresse
alors effectivement
j'ai adhéré un libre à sa création parce
qu'il faut un espace où ça notre famille
politique pour les gens qui ne sont pas
sur la ligne droitière de laurent
wauquiez
j'aurais pu effectivement m'abstenir
d'être candidat comme je voulais dit
s'il y avait une candidature de
consensus d'accord pour autant même si
j'ai beaucoup d'amitié pour alexandra du
blanche
je connais un peu moins bien pierre
bédier ce combat qui s'annonce où ils
sont en train de jouer et ça c'est très
tendu un 1130 jouer probablement en
arrière-plan 2022 et des tribunes
opposées qui sort dans la presse il ya
des parfois des expressions un peu un
peu brute 1 qui sortent comme baron
local ou au fief politique est ce que
vous nous dites entre guillemets que
vous n'auriez pas été candidat s'il y
avait eu un seul candidat pour cette
présidence alors j'aurai certaines ont
pas été candidat s'il y avait eu un seul
un seul candidat pour cette présidence
pour autant que ce soit un candidat de
consensus et qu'ils allaient faire vivre
cette fédération parce qu'il n'a échappé
à personne que cette fédération a été
abandonné pendant trois ans par le
président qui en étaient en charge lui
david douillet vous pensez à lui qu'il
est officiellement encore le président
de la fédération jusqu'en octobre 2018
petite question est ce que vous avez en
ce moment des contacts avec les deux
candidats est ce qu'il ya des
discussions qui s'installe et est-ce
qu'il y en a un qui pourrait
éventuellement tenter de vous séduire
pour vous convaincre et vous vous
retirez et j'irai au bout en gros de
votre mission pour la présidence alors
j'irai au bout
pour autant que je puisse disposer des
parrainages nécessaires
oui bien sûr on connaît pas encore les
règles de parrainage d'actes mans j'ai
rencontré pierre bédier et j'ai
rencontré alexandra du blanche dans des
discussions que je qualifierais
de franche et cordiale un peu viril avec
pierre bédier mais c'est son style tout
le monde tout le monde le connaît
aujourd'hui j'ai bien l'intention de
mener ma candidature à son terme sauf je
vous disais si effectivement il y avait
une candidature de consensus et qu'on
avait la certitude que nous sommes pas
en train de nous engager dans une
nouvelle bataille rangée qui va nous
faire perdre parce que là on parle de la
fédération mais qu'est ce qui se joue
derrière les autres mais les municipales
alors les européennes c'est un scrutin
national c'est un peu différent mais
effectivement vous avez raison c'est les
municipales en selle et départementales
et rien ne prouve vu ce qui s'est passé
pour les législatives qu'on refasse le
grand chelem au département donc en fait
aujourd'hui on a deux conceptions de la
vie politique et de l'organisation de
notre mouvement dans les yvelines qui
s'opposent
j'entends faire entendre ma voix parce
que j'ai des idées voyez je vais vous en
donner quelques unes
cette fédération doit devenir une
fédération digital aujourd'hui on peut
pas faire campagne demandé aux militants
d' aller tracter uniquement quand les
campagnes s'ouvre c'est pas possible
merci jean philippe girod et puis on
suivra forcément cette campagne jusqu'en
octobre 2018 on vous suivra notamment
merci beaucoup d'être venu en plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes candidat pour
l'élection à la présidence de la
fédération yvelines des républicains et
que deux autres candidats sont déjà
connus car bédié alexandra du blanche
merci et bon week-end à vous merci
nicolas on passe maintenant au résumé de
l'actualité de la semaine
les élans courtois l'attendait depuis de
nombreuses années le projet
d'aménagement du secteur des quatre
arbres se précise à elancourt lundi soir
une première réunion publique était
organisée en mairie les 250 habitants
présents se sont vu exposer les grandes
lignes du projet les détails de camille
lambert et miquel et demi d'euros des
locaux commerciaux abandonnés d'autres
vieillissant la zone d'activités des
quatre arba et donc on va être repensé
réaménagement du secteur lancer en 2015
par la ville
lundi 14 mai les habitants étaient
invités en mairie pour une réunion
publique afin de présenter le projet ça
fait très longtemps pendant longtemps
parler mais ça fait très longtemps que
ça n'avance pas beaucoup donc là
j'espère que ça va commencer à à
progresser on est une association gars
on a des jardins et on voudrait savoir
on voudrait connaître l'avenir des
jardins si vous racheter un autre
terrain pour remettre des jardins
ailleurs et pas trop loin parce qu'il ya
des gens qu un certain âge qui n'ont pas
de voiture pour se déplacer la base du
projet prévoit la relocalisation des
jardins familiaux l'enfouissement des
lignes électriques à très haute tension
et plus globalement l'élargissement du
centre ville cette première réunion
marque le début de la phase de
concertation
on n'en est pas encore à la phase projet
avec des définitions de type logique de
bâtiments d'immeubles etc
on en est pour l'instant aux grandes
orientations d'aménagement le but ce
soir est d'expliquer aux gens comment
ils vont pouvoir s'investir dans ce
projet y participer y contribuer à
travers plusieurs réunions publiques des
un diagnostic en marchant qui va être
organisée donc dans quelques semaines
les habitants sont invités à participer
en envoyant leurs homards qui en
s'inscrivant aux ateliers proposés
l'enfouissement des lignes à haute
tension est prévue pour 2020 2022
dans certaines zones les travaux
pourraient commencer plus tôt une
première à la verrière à présent la
ville organisée mercredi après midi son
forum de la parentalité un rendez vous
qui s'est déroulée dans le quartier
d'orly parc des échanges entre des
spécialistes et des parents sur
plusieurs thématiques santé scolarité ou
encore vie à la maison nicolas landry
s'est rendu sur place mercredi reportage
fais pas de sitôt
devenir un enfant de 2 ans tenter de
grimper sur une chaise de se servir à
boire ou d'aller aux toilettes
une activité ludique proposée aux
visiteurs du forum de la parentalité à
la verrière objectif prévenir des
accidents domestiques responsable de 20
mille décès chaque année dont 40 %
d'enfants
alors en fait l'enfant la première chose
qui va voir c'est là que de casseroles
dans ce sens la première chose il va
être attiré par ce qui est à l'intérieur
où tu vas appuyé voyez avec un seul
doigt j'arrive appuyé sur la casserole
et malheureusement la première chose qui
va nous arriver c'est que le liquide
coule sur sa tête et sur les réseaux de
parties du corps donc c'est des brûlures
minimum au deuxième degré pour un enfant
une quinzaine d'exposants des acteurs de
la santé du social ou encore de
l'éducation
l'association dix fois plus fort est
spécialisée dans l'accompagnement des
enfants ayant des troubles de
l'apprentissage
souvent c'est des problèmes de consignes
bien dire les consignes une par une ces
aussi mettre en place des petits
pictogrammes pour que les enfants
puissent avoir des repères et puis c'est
aussi pas faire preuve de patience de la
part des parents c'est un
un événement nouveau sur la ville mais
on pense que effectivement sur une ville
où beaucoup de parents sont deux
familles sont monoparentales notamment
ça peut être intéressant d'avoir comme
ça à un endroit où on va retrouver un
peu tous les sujets de la vie de
l'enfant
une vie dans laquelle les parents ont pu
se plonger durant un après midi tout en
bénéficiant de conseils pour l'éducation
de leurs enfants faire découvrir le
métier de libraire c'est l'un des
objectifs de la quinzaine de la
librairie organisé par la région ile de
france jusqu'au 25 mai une cinquantaine
de rencontre est programmée sur
l'ensemble de la région l'une d'elles se
dérouler mercredi à la librairie du pavé
du canal à montigny le bretonneux
les lycéens du lycée
emilie de bretagne ont pu rencontrer sur
place une auteure reportage de patrick
jacques de dixmude et grégory canal et
ils étaient une vingtaine ce matin à
assister à la rencontre proposée aux
pavés du canal dans le cadre de la
quinzaine de la librairie ses élèves de
première l au lycée breteuil de montigny
le bretonneux ont pu découvrir deux
métiers de la chaîne du livre celui
d'auteur avec joy sorman venu parler de
son ouvrage sciences de la vie la
profession également deux libraires
souvent mal connue par les jeunes c'est
important de d'ouvrir la librairie aux
lycéens de leur montrer que c'est un
lieu voilà qui est facile d'accès quais
ouverts que c'est pas un lieu un peu
sanctuary les excès c'est quelque chose
qui est accessible et ouvert vos
étudiants aussi une action de la région
ile de france pour sensibiliser à
l'univers du livre et de la lecture
chaque jeune reçoit la fin de la
rencontre un chèque de 18 euros à
dépenser dans une librairie le rendez
vous aux pavés du canal a été apprécié
les lycéens ont pu échanger directement
avec le libraire est l'auteur du jour
c'est toujours un plaisir de parler avec
des artistes en fête
surtout quand moi je devenir chanteur
donc même si c'est une écrivain c'est
c'est ça reste une artiste n'a pu
justement donner un travail sur ce qu'on
pense de la littérature aujourd'hui est
plein de choses c'était très présentable
il ya des vraies révélations il ya
quelque chose qui se passe l'écriture un
livre c'est profond et donc ça vient
remuer des questions vraiment intime
parfois et ça veut dire souvent la maman
la quinzaine de la librairie se déroule
jusqu'au 25 mai près d'une cinquantaine
de rencontres va se tenir dans toute
l'île de france
ils interviennent en prison mais aussi
dans votre vie quotidienne et ont pour
objectif de défendre les droits des
usagers face aux dysfonctionnements
généraux des services publics
ils agissent aussi contre toute forme de
discrimination les délégués du défenseur
des droits des yvelines ont dévoilé
mardi à versailles le bilan de leurs
actions en 2017 les onze délégués
présents sur l'ensemble du département
ont notamment porté près de 900
réclamations sur plus de 1600 saisine
attraper et du en cours des permanences
sont ouvertes
un jour par semaine grâce à l'action de
bénévoles ils nous ont expliqué leur
rôle et leur mission extraits de cet
entretien sur des images de patrick
jacques de dixmude
il s'agit vraiment de dysfonctionnement
de service public parce que vous savez
que le délégué défenseur des droits
intervient sur des champs très variés la
déontologie policière les droits de
l'enfant la discrimination
etc c'est vrai que là il s'agit de
dysfonctionnement de service public
alors souvent des questions liées à la
caf à la caisse primaire d'assurance
maladie
les dossiers retraites j'en passe il y
en a d'autres
ce qui veut dire que les gens qui
viennent vous voir sont parfois un peu
désarmée face à la complexité de
l'administration fiscale vous vous êtes
là pour les aider pour la porter votre
expertise soutiens tout à fait la
première chose que l'on fait dans ces
cas là par exemple en matière fiscale
on commence par expliquer le vocabulaire
fiscale les jambes au cou enfin les
administrés ont beaucoup de mal à koné à
comprendre ça cette année on en une
action un peu particulière vous savez
que la déclaration de revenus va être
désormais dématérialisée bien sûr trappe
on a eu on essayait de d'informer les
gens sur ce sujet
la première phase de la nouvelle
plateforme par coups reçus pour
l'inscription dans le supérieur des
élèves s'est achevée le 31 mars les
lycéens apprentis étudiants en
réorientation et candidats inscrits à
l'étranger ont confirmé leurs voeux ils
sont précisément 70 1913 avoir fait la
démarche
dans l'académie de versailles et chacun
pouvait faire plusieurs veut plus de 243
milles se sont portés vers des licences
à l'université et près de 40 470000
excusez moi vers des filières sélectives
classe préparatoire ou encore école
d'ingénieurs à noter que l'académie de
versailles annonce la création de 1500
places supplémentaires afin de répondre
au mieux aux demandes de chaque
c'est un rendez vous national et à
certains égards même internationale qui
débute jeudi prochain au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
des compétitions de désincarcération et
de secours d'urgence entre pompiers
trois jours d'événements couplée à une
campagne de prévention pour tous des
équipes de pompiers de toute la france
et quelques-unes d'autres pays seront
présentes pour l'occasion et par bien
évidemment est des pompiers yvelinois
elles étaient en plateau lundi soir pour
parler de l'événement regard des équipes
yvelinoise composé de 8
sa nouvelle vie sapeurs pompiers
s'entraînent actuellement toutes les
semaines depuis plusieurs mois pour être
prêt pour ce challenge qui se déroule à
domicile
évidemment faire bonne figure et celui
qui l'emportent représentera ensuite la
france toutefois les représentera la
france au challenge mondial qui se
déroulera cette année en afrique du sud
il ya une vraie différence de niveau
alors déjà peut-être au sein même de la
france ait des différentes organisations
des sapeurs pompiers mais aussi avec le
reste du monde aussi une différence de
niveau ou des techniques différentes
c'est aussi l'occasion d'apprendre des
choses peut-être d'échangés l'objectif
principal reste l'échangé au partage des
connaissances techniques opérationnelles
il a forcément une différence de niveau
il ya surtout une différence de deux
techniques de notre façon de procéder
puisque tous les pays ne procède pas de
la même manière non pas les mêmes
matériels n'ont pas les mêmes structures
hospitalières également c'est la fin de
ce set 8 l'hebdo retour de l'information
lundi à 18h mardi excusez moi à 18h sur
tv 78 bon week-end à tous et à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]